it's definitely change I like how a star
player drinks drinks sworn popcorn
machine oh I myself
[Music]
yo guys I'm living off of machines today
in Tokyo gonna die or not it's 9:00 a.m.
I just left my capsule hotel in Shinjuku
and I'm walking around and try to find
this first vending machine and I'm
seeing this is gonna be a lot more
difficult than I thought it was gonna be
every vending machine I've seen so far
only has drinks in it and it's making me
nervous because I feel like I'm not
gonna be able to find any uh any hot
food vending machines like apparently
they're a lot more scarce now than they
were back in the day now mostly it's
just soft drinks and tea and coffee so I
have to figure out how I'm gonna do this
but we're gonna make it happen some of
them and I mean almost right on cue we
found a bunch of stuff in here much of
any machines but like I said they are
all drinks I'll grab a coffee and we'll
leave it at that so this is 100 yen 100
yen put that into there
and let's go do that
nice it's actually pretty good
the worst part he says as I'm walking
through trying to find some food I'm
passing by all of these food places like
oh my god like I can literally eat
anywhere but I'm still trying to find
some stuff from some vending machines
like this is torture so check this out
century they got beans in there all men
I might though he's been at least like a
hour and a half two hours I have yet to
find some food I can actually eat see
they started to get room I can't even
lie
it's actually really bright out here
right now like the Sun is out but the
weather says gonna rain so I'm very
concerned I don't have an umbrella so I
have to go find that it's no food I
don't know what to do I don't want to
die today
I cracked I went over to a spot where I
knew was like so many vending machines
in the only thing I'm gonna be able to
do right now it just grabs - ooh
I know this is coin but I don't know
what that is and that's what I want
so that's 130 and I think I'm just gonna
like bite the bullet and grab it just
had to have some in my body because this
is one o'clock and I haven't eaten
anything
I just been drinking water and in coffee
and caffeine drinks let's just do it
let's just
Oh
actually this most good
it's a couple chunks is something in
here so like I don't think his meets
probably onions but like at least I'm
getting some type of nutrients I'm
getting something
all right I was right it was a bunch of
onions in there like all at the bottom
I guarantee that was like the
instruction on your life
shake well before use that but I don't
know Bianca's gonna be joining me with
some vending machine weight shrimp soup
yeah all right let's see oh my god
that's what I didn't do earlier I didn't
shake my thing it was all at the bottom
this is so funny where does it say that
yep right here oh that's what you don't
speak Japanese
that is good so I do right it's all good
wait so like why cannot find any food I
need some hot food where's the hot food
so the hot food like in the vending
machine it's going to be a kookaburra
it's like this is a nerdy City the
reason why is that down
nobody has to talk that's why thirty
people in Japan don't want to
communicate so they're watching this
Bishop and they have a lunch you know
sounds like me he's getting kind of late
I still haven't had like a solid hot
milk I'm gonna head over to huggy bata
right now alright stopped up the train
in October a low booty sketchy vending
machines
kind of sucks that I feel like I'm gonna
be lost little for them like every video
every video I ever seen
everybody's lost undefined oh you know
Here I am same predicament
alright so that's not what I was looking
for but but this is the can Odin vending
machine so that'll work
so let's see a lot of flow is nasty but
what do it anyway it feels good that
finally got some hot food this is the
can't hold it
we'll see this at work
[Music]
at this point is about survival now
can't be Susie
I wish I knew daddy this is warm water
to live out alerts to something
my game plan now just to eat and ask
questions later legit what the hell is
this
oh my
okay
I just seen the biggest rat he summoned
oh oh gosh
alright so I try this
I have arrogant things
[Music]
oh this is Francie pretty good what
so this drink it's pretty tasty like
wants to see your mouth but I truly see
the dilemma because once you put it up
here like wouldn't get to see a nose you
got a you know be smelling and trying to
sit get real tricky cuz that thing I see
this sketchy-ass place and I will agree
here look super sketchy but I mean can't
be as sketchy as walking down Hollywood
Boulevard so let's get on up in here we
open the hot spot it is definitely
creepy in here this is when it gets a
little sketchy this is weird
it's like several crevices like you got
a slide don't tell me I came all this
way in a sketchy area in the dirt just
to get some food to find out ain't even
got no candy
dang got no chips what I got you what I
got you Thanks they definitely doesn't
[ __ ] imma grab some of those it's not
something that's Himalayan salt I'm
gonna get I'm gonna get those even
though I mean truthfully got anybody to
help me survive but I think it's cool it
had to be an interesting story for my
kids like I just order this out the
black market you know this is what this
feels like
this is the black market in real life
but it's no hot flu so it's just like
what am i doing
I'm literally wasting money oh I've seen
these before I did a video u.s. versus
Japan snacks and this is one of the
sticks and then we'll get some popcorn
get the machine work just to that one
see how it work
okay
this must be full yet move I'm being
completely honest when I tell you this
just how quick this trick I'm actually
surviving off of vending machine food in
Tokyo yeah I thought oh and I like all
the deal about you you might die bro
trying to do something right in there
now look me driving
of course I make it here after it's not
raining anymore but since I'm here
that's okay I will for a souvenir
all right so I'm looking for the glass
vending machine stuff all the hot food
and I can't believe it like I'm in the
right here you this is literally the end
this is like we're supposed to be like
oh you did it like this is the spot
where you finally get your hot food and
I cannot find it
all right so fun area is hella vending
machines over here like mavin regime's
look at all these damn drinks and then I
went on more drinks I just be one was my
food Oh
this can't be happening right now this
can't this can't be happening right now
Oh yo this has to be a joke whoa whoa
whoa I've traveled long and far just to
get a piece of this machine I don't even
know what this say but I probably say
you leave look all these options I got a
hot dog another hot dog some fries it's
a rat I don't think I've ever been more
disappointed before in my life like I
feel like this is easily the worst way
to in this video like or maybe the best
for y'all but for me this is the worst
way to end this like day oh my god I
can't believe this like a part of you
want to just like make it like rip this
off just to see if it really don't work
I guess the next best thing is just to
get some ice cream and call it a day
Wow I'm hurt my feelings is hurt hurt
I'm not crying I'm not not strawberry
ice cream
I got a nice umbrella I had a good time
made some new friends not really but it
was all good on the bright side it's
rainin now
so I could be used my new home fella
that makes me very happy so
is everything perfect no of course this
is some pretty nice indeed I'm not mad
[Music]